قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان ايران تخوض
حرب استنزاف ضد اسرائيل عبر وكلائها
القريبين من حدود اسرائيل وانها حولت سفن
تجاريه الى معسكرات عائمه للارهاب في
مسارات الملاحه البحريه واضاف وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه ان كل الخيارات يجب ان تكون
على الطاوله لمنع ايران من حيازه سلاح
نووي كما حذر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
ايران من تبعات زياده نسبه تخصيب
اليورانيوم الى تسعين بالمئه واكد غلاند
ان اسرائيل ضاعفت هجماتها لمنع محاولات
ايران التمركز عسكريا في سوريا
نقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن رئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه اللواء هارون حليفه
قوله ان من العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسب
نصر الله يقترب من ارتكاب خطا قد يدفع
المنطقه الى حرب الكبرى واضاف حليفه ان
نصر الله سامحها باطلاق مسيرات من سوريا
ما قد يتسبب في تصعيد كبير في المنطقه
نفذ حزب الله اللبناني مناوره ميدانيه في
احد معسكرات جنوب لبنان تضمنت محاكاه
لعمليه اسر جنود اسرائيليين واقتحام
مستوطنه اسرائيليه وتفجير جدار الاسبنتي
بين لبنان واسرائيل وعبور مئات المقاتلين
الحدود واستعرض حزب الله في المناوره
اسرابا من الطائرات المسيره وقصفها لبواقع
اسرائيليه وتاتي هذه المناوره قبيل ايام
من احياء لبنان ذكرى انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من جنوبي لبنان عام 2000
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا الان من القدس مراسع الجزيره
الياس كرام اذا الياس تصريحات لوزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي تصاحبها ايضا تصريحات
لرئيس شعبه الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه ما
الذي يقتضى كل هذه التصريحات الاسرائيليه
فيما يخص ايران وكما يقولان وكلائها في
المنطقه
ايران غابت عن تصريحات الاسرائيليين في
الاسابيع والشهور الاخيره نظرا للاوضاع
الداخليه في اسرائيل ونظرا ايضا للاوضاع
الامنيه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وكذلك
في قطاع غزه وهنالك رغبه كما يبدو من جانب
الساسه في اسرائيل الى اعاده الملف
الايراني الى الواجهه من جديد وهذا كان
بارزا من خلال كلمات عدد من المسؤولين
السياسيين والعسكريين على هامش مؤتمر
هرتسليه السنوي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والامنيه لكن المهم في خطاب وزير الدفاع
يقف قلند انه يحدد ربما خطوطا حمراء من
وجهه نظر اسرائيل فيما يخص
العلاقه مع ايران او فيما يخص التعامل مع
برنامجها النووي العسكري
وجالنت يقول بان
الملف النووي الايراني اصبح على مفترق طرق
مصري وهو يقول او يصف هذه الحاله بان
الملف النووي الايراني اشبه بقطار سيدخل
الى نفق واذا دخل هذا
القطار الى نفق فانه لن يخرج منه الا
وبايران بحيازتها سلاحا نوويا وهذا يعني
بان هذا سيشكل خطرا استراتيجيا على العالم
وخطرا وجوديا على اسرائيل ومن هذه الناحيه
يقول وهو يحدد ربما للمره الاولى وبشكل
علني خطا احمرا امام النظام الايراني حيث
يقول لانه اذا تجاوزت ايران تخصيبا
اليورانيوم الى تسعين في المئه فان هذا
سيكلف ايران اثمانا باهضه وسيكون له
تداعيات خطيره على منطقه الشرق الاوسط في
هذا السياق يقول يعظ جالنت بان اذرع الامن
الاسرائيليه كافه الاذرع الامن
الاسرائيليه في جهد استثنائي ومركز لمنع
ايران من تحقيق هدفها وتحقيق ابو لوغي
القدره او اجتياز العتبه النوويه لحيازه
السلاح النووي وان في هذا في هذه الحاله
في هذه الحاله اسرائيل تضع كل الخيارات
على الط كل الخيارات وهو شدد على هذا
الامر مرتين في هذا السياق طبعا يقف قلند
شيطنه النظام الايراني وقال بان ايراني هي
المسؤوله عن تصدير الارهاب للعالم وهي
المسؤوله عن تصدير الارهاب في الشرق
الاوسط وان ايران تخوض حرب استنزاف
ويستخدم هذا المصطلح ربما للمره الاولى
وباعتراف واضح ورسمي بان ايران تخوض حرب
استنزاف مع اسرائيل عبر وكلائها في
المنطقه او عبر وكلائها المحيطين بحدود
اسرائيل وهو يقصد بذلك حزب الله ويقصد
بذلك ايضا المقاومه الفلسطينيه سواء كان
ذلك في قطاع غزه او في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله يقف قلند في سياق هذه الكلمه قال
بان ايران هي التي تمول وتسلح وتجند كل
الارهابيين الذين يعملون على المساسي
باسرائيل من وجهه نظره او كما قال من
ناحيه اخرى كشف جلنط على ان الحرس الثوري
الايراني يعمل على تحويل سفن تجاريه
الى ما سماها معسكرات عائمه ارهابيه
متقدمه وقادره على بلوغ اهداف بعيدا عن
الحدود الايرانيه من اجل بث الارهاب كما
قال وهذه السفن التجاريه يقول بان الحرس
الثوري الايراني سلحها بمسيرات وبصواريخ
وبقوات كوماندوز وبقدرات الاستخباراتيه
وقدرات بحريه قادره على توجيه ضربات او
عمليات ارهابيه كما سماها خارج نطاق حدود
ايران سواء كان ذلك في المحيط الهندي او
في البحر الاحمر وان هذا يشكل خطوره بمكان
على المسارات البحريه
المختلفه
الرام كنت معنا من القدس شكرا جزيلا لك